[Music]
quantum computing is not just better
computing faster computing it's a
different kind of computing it's
predicted to solve some of the world's
most fundamental problems from inventing
new drugs to making brand-new materials
and creating more precise climate models
it could solve some problems in seconds
that would take current supercomputers
thousands of years the technology is in
its early stages but the effort is
quickly gaining momentum so how well
quantum computing changed the world a
standard computer might have billions of
bits each one can be a 1 or a 0 and
they're all completely separate from
each other quantum bits or qubits work
differently for a couple of reasons that
come from quantum mechanics thanks Jason
but let's not go down that rabbit hole
all you need to know is this the theory
shows that certain kinds of problems not
all just some particularly thorny ones
are made much easier when you've got
quantum computers one of those problems
is in encryption the kinds of codes that
protect your credit card details online
or your messages in whatsapp or signal
what caught people really interested in
making corner computers was the
realization that they could break
encryption that was supposed to be too
hard to crack because regular computers
couldn't crack them that's the kind of
thing that gets the attention of
national governments the ability to
crack other countries encrypted networks
as in the case of artificial
intelligence China says it intends to
lead the world in quantum science and
has announced plans to open its own
national quantum laboratory to open in
2020 America is getting involved too
it intends to create a national quantum
initiative that's because the prize that
quantum computing offers the potential
strategic or commercial advantage is
huge
imagine if you could make
minute-to-minute real-time stock
predictions based on data from every
trade ever made or if you could simply
compute the formula for a new fuel or a
drug that beats a horrible disease
that's the kind of promise the quantum
computing may offer there are already
quantum computers out there but it's a
bit like the situation with regular
computers in the 1950s big basement
sized things that required a pile of
PhDs
operate and they still weren't very
powerful typewriter like keyboard is the
master control setting up data and
instructions on a punch tape which in
turn feeds the electronic computer
there's a huge effort to make more
powerful quantum computers this used to
be the stuff of university physics
departments but you can see the
potential when you see who's in the
business now it's big names like Google
Microsoft IBM but it's not just about
when one day one company or one lab
invents this one computer it's going to
be a bunch of small advances towards the
kind that's commercially available
reliable and can really solve some of
these big problems here's the thing when
we talk about quantum computing people
tend to think of all singing
all-powerful machine that can run any
kind of program what's called a
universal computer that's still a
distant prospect but in the mean time
there will be smaller machines more
specific purpose less general purpose
these things are incredibly hard to run
they're held at temperatures lower than
that of deep space in very very
controlled laboratory environments even
if you could just pick one up off the
shelf
you wouldn't yes they're incredibly
powerful for some kinds of problems but
they're not going to replace the kind of
computer on your desk or in your phone
you don't need quantum powers to edit
photos or send emails in fact what will
probably happen is that a few companies
have the best computers and you can use
them on a kind of timeshare basis in the
cloud or you send off your gnarly
quantum problem and just get an answer
back but the kinds of problems that
we'll be able to pose the kinds of
answers we'll be able to get are
absolutely unthinkable now and that's
what has governments industry giants and
plucky startups in on the race